hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website common today we are in
round 8 of our coverage the 2018 Tata
Steel tournament our competitors whites
gonna be played by Magnus Carlsen the
world champion looking to get a victory
and catapult himself to its high a first
place in the tournament
his opponent today playing the black
pieces Godwin Jones if you're not too
familiar with the 30-year old English
grandmaster he won the Challenger event
last year at the Tata Steel that's why
he is in this tournament at the Masters
level but he is the lowest rated player
in the tournament so far but fortunately
for him he's having a great tournament
only one point off of first place so
looking to get a huge victory here and
catapult himself near the top of the
leaderboard as well one thing about
Godwin Jones is he likes to play very
aggressive defenses as black so always
nice to see someone playing aggressive
his black again someone that likes to
play aggressive for whites will go and
get started with Magnus Carlsen pawn to
e4 pawn c5 Sicilian events extremely
aggressive Knight to f3 pawn d6 pawn d4
normal exchange like we see in the
Sicilian defense Knight f6 Knight c3 and
then pawn to g6 this is the dragon
variation one of the more aggressive
ways that black can continue in the
Sicilian defense what interesting is
afterwards Magnus Carlsen says he was
surprised to see the dragon variation
from Gowen now if you know anything
about Godwin Jones you know that he's a
well renowned author and he literally
has two books called the dragon because
this is his favorites defense in the
Sicilian offense as you can imagine if
you have a favorite defense you might as
well bring this out against the big boys
managed Carlsen being the world champion
so I don't think it was that big of a
shock uh I'm not sure if Magnus Carlsen
actually was too surprised but he did
say that he did not expect to see the
dragon events play - cause he has two
options here he's more the classical
Bishop to e2 Castle on the Kings side
and your normal variation not super
aggressive I'd not try to get into any
sharp plays or difficult
additions but he decides to go more of
the aggressive usually you'll see this
if you're much higher rank than your
opponent you want to get into these very
complicated positions that you feel like
at the end of the day that you can come
out ahead and that is the yoga Slav
attack and that is Bishop to e3 Bishop
g7 feeding kettle on the kingside pawns
to f3 so solidify this pawn chain and
then play Queen to d2 getting ready to
castle onto the Queen side and after
this two sides castle this is very very
sharp opening both sides are gonna have
very difficult positions and any time
you see castling on opposite sides of
the board both sides are gonna be just
throwing everything they can at their
opponents King just because they don't
have to worry about extending pieces or
the pawns space on the board they can
just start attacking as much as possible
so definitely has an exciting game at
getting ready to take place we see got
one play pawn to a d5 Queen back here to
e 1 upon 2 e5 so really pushing in the
center of the board and then it takes on
c6 pawn recaptures and then after the
Knight takes here on a d5 you see got
one doing good job of controlling the
center of the board he does have an
isolated pawn here on c6 Magnus Carlsen
has the better pawn structure but you
can see it's kind of just holding back
right here not trying to commit too much
as far as his material past this third
rank here just trying to see feel his
opponent out see if there's any
weaknesses and then from there continues
his play Bishop to c4 completing his
development here
Bishop down here to e6 just defending
this night here on a d5 90s plays King
to a b-1 want to make sure that you get
it to a safer Square here on b1 rook to
e8 and then Knight to e4 Magnus Carlsen
took 21 minutes on this move he had a
couple options
he has your normal pawn to h4 just
starting to push everything on the King
side of the board I really like this
move could have also played Bishop to b3
really safe squared just more of a
waiting move to see what your opponent's
going to do this is something that Bobby
Fischer used to
a lot of bike Fisher would sometimes
even play pawn to a3 just camp his
bishop back here did not want to lose
this wanted to put a lot of pressure on
his opponent especially since
everything's being thrown at the Kings
side the board from black wants to make
sure that he does have this LightSquared
Bishop attacking his opponent but in the
game decided to play Knight to e4 didn't
feel like he was great in this position
but Knight to e4 is the move and then we
see f5 this is a novelty something we
haven't really seen in at this opening
too much but attacking the knight and
that comes up here to g5 and this is a
interesting situation on board because
what what Godwin did a good job of is he
was playing so fast it was almost like
Magnus Carlsen was trying to sit there
and figure out like why is he playing so
fast these are some very complicated
positions does he just know everything
going on right now he's not taking a lot
of time I'm taking 21 minutes and he's
just rapid-fire snapping off his moves
after Knight to g5 you can see the
bishop here on e3 is protecting it yes
this is attacking the bishop so
depending on if goblin wants to exchange
material but this Queen here on d8 is
attacking so want to make sure that
Magnus Carlsen holds on to this material
with his bishop here on e3 gamma decides
he does not want to give up his Bishop
Harrison brings the bishop back here to
c8 and here's where things get
interesting Magnus Carlsen makes a huge
blunder and he plays pawn up here to g4
unfortunately for him this opens up the
door for pawn to f4 and as you can see
from what we just talked about this
Knight here is no longer defended we're
already seeing the bishop here on e3
being attacked but now the knight no
longer has protection would have been
much better if Magnus Carlsen played
pawn to H for this attacks on the Kings
side the board has a great outpost here
for this Knight here on a g5 and then
the bishop can freely move if pawn down
to f4 not a problem at all can easily
move the bishop this Knight right now is
being pinned down by this bishop to the
king so he's not gonna be moving anytime
soon but this would be a much better
spot but
Karlsson blenders a piece and it was
kind of interesting after this happened
you started to see some of the players
who had finished their games start to
move around the table as they're walking
by seeing what's going on
the commentators are freaking out we
haven't really seen Magnus Carlsen
blunder a move like this especially
early on in a game we're only on move 17
right now so very odd as far as how
Magnus Carlsen did this afterwards he
just said it was a terrible move he felt
terrible about it you could see it in
his body language if you were watching
the live streams was not happy about his
play did not take long before guy want
to play after pawns who aged four to
just go ahead and take the material here
on e3 madness Carlsen was able to get a
pawn back so that's the only thing he
had to show for it recognizing that he
was gonna lose material so it's decided
to start pushing forward on the king's
head with this pawn come back here with
Queen takes here on e3 pawn h6 forcing
the the Knights move but we do have an
in-between move of Queen to h2 c5 this
does delay because you don't want the
pawn to take now on g5 because then you
would see the Queen takes on c6 this
Knights would fall and so all in all
this would end up being a good position
for white let's say the bishop comes
down now to e6
we could see an exchange in the stern of
the board rook takes on d5 let's say the
the Queen's come off the board all in
all this is gonna be much better for
Magnus Carlsen than the position he was
and not necessarily this is good for
Magnus Carlsen but definitely better
than the position he was in
so we see God when a correctly decided
to play Bishop to b7 a knight down here
to e4 since it was being attacked by the
pawn here on h6 now rook down to e6 and
then punt up here to h5 one thing that
we did notice on the board is after h5 a
few things start to happen here we
really need black to play pawn to g5
this is a a critical Square that he
needs to have but he doesn't and
said he takes a long time and then
decides that what he really needs to do
is exchange off the Queen so he plays
Queen to b6 and just really doesn't keep
in mind the fact that he needs to have
some protection in front of his king
pawn to g5 great solidifying this pawn
chain over here doesn't have to worry
about King site safety anymore does not
need to be playing this Queen to a b6
now we see pawn up to g5 Magnus Carlsen
trying to blow up the king side the
board we do see an exchange on board and
then the Queen comes back here to a3 man
mr. Carlson not quite looking to
exchange off his queen he can sense
something going on the board he wants to
make sure he has his powerful pieces
there right now you can see the Queen
attacking this pawn on a7 the rook and
the Queen are both defending it right
now first we see the rook to b8 so
definitely getting into a better Square
semi-open file for the rook to get
involved but still holding down this
pawn here on a7 by the Queen after pawn
up here to a b3 what's interesting as we
see Queen back here to d8 I think
another option much stronger forgotten
would have been Bishop to f8 still
holding down this pawn on a7 this does
attack the Queen here on a3 forcing
Magnus Carlsen to move and then he can
reevaluate after that but Queen back
here to d8 seems more of a defensive
move not really aggressive on the board
right now and then you see Queen come up
here take here on a 7 then the pawn
takes rook takes here up here on h5 and
you can start to see things are much
weaker on the kingside board the rook
can start to swing over here to h1 if he
wants to attack this Bishop still
pinning down material to the King the
knight can come over here start to take
material Knight takes on g5 as an option
here so this earlier that pawn to g5 was
such a critical move that gawad missed
now you can see rook to g6 trying to
hold on to the material unfortunately
for Jones it does not do what he was
hoping for because yes the Queen looks
like it is defending the square but it's
actually not the rook takes the rook
takes and then the Knights
to recapture the Queen cannot take here
if we were to say Queen to g5 this would
be extremely bad now we see the rook
fall on the eights and then check Bishop
to FA trying to stop that the bishops
gonna fall just losing way too much
material that's going to be a bad option
so he looks at this and says okay it
lost a pawn right here that's not good
you can see Madison starting to chip
away now has two pawns in exchange for
his opponent's minor piece on the board
and Godwin at the same time not being
aggressive with his material so Queen
comes back here to a c8 work over here
to g1 so once these pieces start to move
the king will be under attack rook here
to a eights Queen down here to B 6 and
then rook to a6 and this is where things
get even more complicated it's very
tricky to look at all these permutations
that both sides can go through the
knight would like to take the Queen here
on b6 but the bishop would take the king
that would be an illegal move the bishop
would like to take the rook here on a
six but the bishop can't move because
the knight would no longer be pinned
down and then the knight could just take
the Queen here on b6 so a lot of stuff
to think about for both sides of the
board all you have to know is if any of
these pieces really move or the King
moves it's no longer being pinned down
fireworks can happen at any time so from
here we see the Queen come down here to
c5 a queen to a d7 Knight over here to
e4 just centralizing a little bit King
to h8 so this Knight is free to move
also this Bishop is free to move as well
Mathis Carlsen decides even beyond
taking this rook here on a6 he found a
better move and that is getting the
Queen and BOM to the game looking to
bring his queen over here to h5 start a
strong attack on his opponents Gowen
decides yeah I needed to go ahead and
stop this so plays Queen over here to e7
stopping the Queen coming to h4 but as
you can imagine this does leave that
rook here on a6
exposed the bishops able to take that
after the bishop takes Queen over
here H to check and you can start to see
magnus carlsen gaining even more
advantage now he has both the material
advantage he also has a much better
attack against his opponent no pawns in
front of jones's King here all of a
sudden Magnus Carlson's King is looking
very safe here on b1 now Queen up here
to h6 saying yes I'm just gonna get this
in the best position possible you can't
take it because your Bishop is pinned
down by the rook Queen back over here to
a seventh queen to e6 attacking the King
King f8 sriq up here to g5 so just
slowly getting his position a little bit
better and I down here to e3 stopping
you know some of the material coming
here to f5 but there's so many attacks
that Magnus Carlsen has Queen to d6 one
of those attacking King to f7 Knight to
c5 attacking both the bishop also
attacking a strong attack but you can
see Queen to e6 being one of those just
so many so many ways to manage Carlson
has to attack here
Bishop up here to c8 stopping the square
here on both east six and a d7 for
Magnus Carlsen to go to and then the
dagger and that is rook to g7 there's no
way to really stop this and at the end
of a guy when Jones decides to resign if
he were to play people always ask how
this game would continue King to f8
couldn't go fa maybe he were to side to
play King to be 8 that's one option okay
rook to g8 and then we have a quick maid
after that okay well if he decides
instead to take that material King takes
on g7 well now we have Queen to e5 check
and then that night is going to fall at
the end of the day Manish Carlsen is up
three pawns he does have a much more
aggressive position he has a passed pawn
here the King is exposed this would be a
very very easy in game for mattis cross
in to convert so congratulations to
Magnus Carlsen he is now tied
first in the tournament somewhat
unfortunate for forgotten Jones this is
one of those games have probably looked
back he always is not playing these high
level players so this being his first
real Masters Tournament playing against
the best of the best you could see that
he had his opening he was prepared and
went exactly like you gonna hoped for
and at the end of the day I think just
maybe got a little nervous Magnus
Carlsen even being down a minor piece
still gonna put so much pressure on you
in that opening it with the dragon
variation the Sicilian still very sharp
play that Godwin had to maneuver and at
the other day just made a few mistakes
here and there at the end and magnus
carlsen was able to convert so at the
end of day not to the result he was
expecting but many players we're looking
on and congratulated him on playing such
a strong game and making Manish Carlsen
really earned that victory but hopefully
you guys enjoyed round 8 it's been a
fantastic tournament some really really
exciting games and I will see you guys
tomorrow and round number nine